Two of the most noted features of DNA
are that it's double-stranded and in a spiral,
or helical, shape. Thus, we call it the
double helix. But for us to understand how
DNA does what it does so well, we really need to simplify this model even more.
We need to simplify both of these basic
features. So, first, we're going to unwind our DNA.
And now, we actually want to separate
the double stranded DNA into two single strands.
And looking at one of these single strands, we can immediately see the basic
unit of DNA called the Deoxynucleotide. Deoxynucleotides
are just the basic building blocks that make up DNA. In fact, looking at this
single strand here, which structure do you think is the deoxynucleotide?